الصحفي كل الزملاء يهم الففف عافيه
الصاروخ في مواجهه الكاميرا لكن قوته
التدميريه تعجز عن كسر ضوئها الفاضح سامر
معايا في المكان ماشي
بمر المكان وين المكان وين المكان هذه غزه
بالطبع وتلك ليست الا جمله تحاول اختزال
حكايات تتكرر هناك منذ وائل الدحدوح الذي
استانف مهمته على شاشه الجزيره بعد ساعات
من فقد زوجته واطفاله في قصف اسرائيلي الى
وائل الدحدوح الذي استانف مهمته على شاشه
الجزيره للمره الثانيه بعدما اصيب بجروح
مرورا بنحو 90 صحفيا قتلتهم اله الغزو
المتوحشه ولم يكن اخرهم زميله وصديقه الذي
استشهد الى جانبه سامر ابو
دق خلف الصاروخ يقف جندي مدجج باسباب
الموت قد يكون اسمه دافيد او كوهين او
حييم او شحار وخلف الكاميرا يقف صحفي
مملوء باسباب الحياه قد يكون اسمه سامر او
هشام او ياسر او محمد من مكمنه وسط البرج
الحصين او الدبابه الحديثه يضغط الاول على
زر الاطلاق فيدمر منزلا دافئا او مربعا
سكنيا على رؤوس قاطنيه خلال ثوان قليله
ومن موقعه تحت الشمس الساطعه او السماء
الممطره يقبض الثاني على عدسه التصوير
ويديرها ليفضح جريمه مروعه او عمليه اباده
ترتكب الان كما على مدى عقود سلفات تحت
شعار حق الدفاع عن
النفس واذ صار ملايين البشر في مختلف
ارجاء الارض يفتحون عيونهم في اي ساعه من
ساعات الليل والنهار على شاشات يتدفق منها
دم المدنيين اطفالا ونساء ورجالا فان
الجناه الذين من فكوا يدرون عطف العالم
بوصفهم ضحايا الفاشيه لا يجدون خيارا للحد
من تدفق الصور التي تفضح جرائمهم سوى
اضافه الصحفيين الى ما يسمى بنك الاهداف
قتل الشهود اذا هو المراد الذي تكاد
التحليلات تجمع على اعتباره تفسيرا وحيدا
لسقوط ما يقرب من 100 صحفي فلسطيني بالنار
الاسرائيليه خلال 70 يوما فضلا عن اكثر من
100 اخرين سبقوهم على مدى خمسه عقود ونيف
مرت منذ احتلال الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
وافلت قتلتهم من العقاب عزاؤنا
الوحيد اننا
مستمرون الاهم في حكايات هؤلاء الذين
اصابتهم الصواريخ فاستشهدوا او قصص اولئك
الذين اخطاتم القذائف
فنجوا انهم لم يتوبوا عن القيام بواجبهم
او بحياتهم في سبيل الدفاع عن
انسانيتهم تدمر الصواريخ بيوتهم وتقتل
اطفالهم فينهض من وسط الدمار ليخبروا
العالم بما حدث او يتمسكون بالبقاء فوق
الركام حتى حين تتوفر لهم فرصه الهجره الى
الشمال ي قد
مشتا علمني
الفراح قلبي بعدك ض والمر يا بداك يرحل
سامر ابو دقه عن بلجيكا حيث تعيش اسرته
تاركا طفله هناك يغني يا بش قد مشتاق
عذبني الفراج ويعود الى غزه لان فيها
جنديا غازيا لا يتورع عن ان يهدي طفلته في
عيد ميلادها تفجير مبنى سكني ولا بد من
فضحه ايا كان
الثم